paper straws are bad for the universe
new study shows that there are toxic
chemicals in there according to this
study the straws contain poly and per
fluoroalkyl substances bfas which are
long lasting potentially destructive to
human health but who cares about that
and we've got to prioritize the Delta
smelt over human beings these days
they're also bad for the environment
according to Dr Timo groffen
from the University of Antwerp straws
made from plant-based materials such as
paper and bamboo are often advertised as
being more sustainable and eco-friendly
but the pfas in there means that is not
necessarily the case they looked at 39
different straw Brands and it turns out
that they're all pretty pretty bad for
the environment yeah of course this
always happens we're always proven right
about these things and so here's my
recommendation I've made this
recommendation on the show before
with regard to totally different kinds
of issues my recommendation is be normal